if the world warms by three degrees the
Arctic is ice-free all summer the Amazon
rainforest is drying out snow caps on
the Alps all but disappear
El Ninos extreme weather patterns become
the status quo the Mediterranean and
parts of Europe wither in searing summer
heat this could be our world plus three
degrees
in a three degree warmer world these
kinds of summer heat waves will just be
the norm so an extremely hot summer but
this point will actually bring the kinds
of temperatures into Central Europe that
you now experienced in the Middle East
and in northern Africa the summer of
2003 may have opened a window unto life
in a world that's three degrees warmer
all across Europe an unrelenting heat
wave developed into a natural disaster
Paris tends to empty in the summer many
elderly stay behind nobody could have
anticipated the danger they'd be in
[Music]
emergency room doctors were the first to
realize something was terribly wrong
emergency room doctor Patrick Pulu
quickly realizes the heat wave is
turning into a catastrophe was that even
a vague notion you had such a heat wave
comparable to a flame thrower igniting
an entire area the number of people who
died on the night of August 10 is
between 2,500 and 3,000 the death toll
would top 30,000 across Europe and
France alone over 14,000 died in just a
few weeks laughter each wave of 2003 was
probably the first huge catastrophe due
to global warming that affected a rich
country the rich country that showed
itself to be protected from everything
ah seafood well that was wrong
you